la crainte des dd deschamps envers les
outils numériques de lutte contre la
pandémie me semble parfaitement légitime
cette l'association la cadrature du net
dont vous avez entendu parler qui à mon
avis réalise un travail absolument
remarquable et a vraiment développé un
thème d' alerte sur le fait que par
exemple l'application tout senti qu vide
n'est que le prélude à une surveillance
beaucoup plus pérenne et invasive de
l'état sur l'attitude des gens la
difficulté de l' usage de ces outils
numériques
c'est que passée la pandémie passer la
crise sanitaire
ces outils subsisteront la réticence des
uns et des autres face à cette politique
sanitaire s'explique par une crainte de
voir l'état les surveiller de façon
beaucoup plus intrusive voire
totalitaire à un moment donné lorsque la
justification initiale sera dépassé
l'esprit de résistance des gens face à
cette politique sanitaire n'est pas
seulement un effet de complotisme ou
quant à soi bien gaulois comme avait dit
de manière bien filmé le président
macron il ya quelques mois n'est ce pas
cette aussi un souci bien compréhensible
de ce que l'état mène des politiques
nécessaires mais pas plus et ça c est un
dialogue constant entre le gouvernement
l'état et les citoyens c'est ça une
démocratie
[Musique]